[Musique]
au forum d'un international d'internet
déjà en 2018 le président de la
république parlait déjà de corégulation
et avec un éclatement au passage des
souverainetés entre souveraineté
fonctionnel aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
plutôt attribué aux gaffes à et puis les
souverainetés territoriales plutôt aux
états elles l'ont abandonnée dans les
années 2000 en adoptant une doctrine
d'innovation qui interdisait aux états
de mener des politiques industrielles
fortes
alors il ya beaucoup de retard qui a été
pris si on pense bien sûr aux états unis
à la chine ou à la russie mais c'est pas
impossible donc il est très urgent de
mettre en place une politique
industrielle sur les questions
numériques
[Musique]
oui pour répondre simplement puisque
aujourd'hui capte nos données
personnelles l'ensemble des données
personnelles et à échelle mondiale
puisque aujourd'hui ce sont des visions
du monde qui sont hégémonique c'est ce
qu'on appelle le désamour et parce que
tout simplement les données personnelles
sont le carburant qui vient entraîné les
algorithmes d'intelligence artificielle
qui sont le vector aujourd'hui de la
valeur économique
legatum menace notre vie privée parce
que ils ont ils mettent en relation de
2,2 les différents domaines de nos
propres vies domaine professionnel de
nos déplacements notre vie personnelle
aux intérêts culturels etc
et à partir de ça ils sont capables de
générer des modèles de prédiction ces
modèles sont très forts et donc
permettre de savoir ce qu'on va faire à
mon même souvent que nous même en ayant
conscience
donc on voit bien les dangers qui sont
liées à ça
[Musique]
alors que trump stricto sensu soit lui
censure et quand il dit des bêtises ce
n'est pas un danger pour la démocratie
le fait qu' on puisse fac checker en
direct une information et puis censuré
ou mettre un bandeau qui explique que
telle ou telle information qui a été
donnée est fausse et plutôt salutaire
bien sûr que ça pose la question de
savoir qui a le droit de certaine façon
d'établir ce qui est acceptable ou pas
comme discours et là aussi ça renvoie à
une unité démocratique pour exercer ce
contrôle éventuel sion sur l'information
et c'est pas le cas si c'est consentis à
des entreprises privées
[Musique]
je